yeah okay just I'll go open it shiny
doors and [ __ ] off yeah okay so I think
you owe me like 250 for the movie but
you can baby run away I'll give it you
right now one sec so soon are you owe me
300 for the uber app and so for that
mini punjakadan Oh also 300 for the
popcorn and coke and 1000 for that gun
diwali vine chill no we sort it out hey
how do you think this looks it's nice I
mean where are you going I am going for
a party mm-hmm thanks hey our date night
every sync key oh shoot Joe Carthage
other what is wrong with you who is this
- a date are you crazy
do you ever want to get laid oh hey by
the way my mom's coming from boys how
long is she gonna escape I don't know
like two three weeks maybe yeah my mom's
gonna be here in half an hour they will
can eat addiction Shepherd away I have a
work thing you have anything formal that
I can borrow yeah I think I should have
a black shot that's right in front yeah
I just check this one yeah your Papa's
gonna put these back in my cupboard over
oh hey um if you don't mind could you
smoke next to the window I'm so sorry I
need your lies Shawn okay
maiden window
he's my boyfriend for me to meet that
one hi nice to meet you
x-man press X highs today can we please
go on hungry it was like one super big
piece and greenish-yellow you know it's
tangled karateka Paula Bunyan